image that I've used before I don't
think I've used it in this class it
takes off from Heraclitus statement that
you cannot step into the same river
twice thinking of time and the passage
of time as being a river and I maintain
that that while that is obviously true
it is very important when you do step
into the river
whether you are facing upstream or
downstream and historians face
downstream they don't know what's going
on but they see it as it passes them the
turbidity of the water the ripples the
currents the flotsam and jetsam floating
along maybe a fish jumping or something
and they see the pattern as it flows
past them and in some cases the farther
downstream the water flows the more
apparent the pattern is and so this is
or the trade of historians other people
say people in political world in
particular step into the stream facing
upstream and they have water in their
face and foam and they can't see a damn
thing for more than about three inches
so they don't you know projecting
patterns forward if you do not have a
historical view of what they were in the
past really is almost impossible to do
as witness the thousand and one
different interpretations for example of
the Arab Spring and what may come next
great story alright so so I'm interested
in the patterns of the past and
obviously in a world history textbook
the structure of the book implies
patterns even if they are not explicitly
spelled out so that in the chapter I've
asked you to read for this week the one
dealing with the Ottoman Empire the
Safavid Empire
and the Mughal Empire as well as with
what I call the maritime empires of
Islam
and the European extension into the
Indian Ocean about there's question of
what is the what is the underlying
pattern that would that would justify
this kind of grouping of topics there
are a couple that are fairly obvious but
are not necessarily the ones that the
authors had in mind for example is this
simply talking about have a chapter to
say what were the Muslims doing between
1500 and 1750 is it just sort of
grouping the Muslims and since the
Ottoman Empire and the Safavid Empire in
Iran and the Mughal Empire in India were
indeed Islamic states and were arguably
the most powerful and influential
Islamic States now you could say well
yes that that is sort of what it is but
that is that was not what was in the
minds of the authors when they carved
out this chapter because they were very
conscious that there were other parts of
the Muslim world
for example Morocco has a a kingdom that
is very robust this time you have a
number of very important in Islamic
polities arising in West Africa and you
have Islamic policies in Central Asia
north of the Ottoman Empire and north of
the of Iran and what now is Pakistan but
then was the Northwest Frontier of India
and these Islamic policies are not
covered so this is not meant to be
what's happening with Islam between 1500
and 1750 there is the old rubric and I
mentioned before the notion of gunpowder
empires this was a phrase that was
coined by Marshall Hodgson who has
written a very influential very long and
well let's say the influential and long
three-volume work called the venture of
Islam that is highly admired in some
quarters and he said that this is a
period in Islamic history that you have
you know four beginnings of Islam then
you have the classical Caliphate and
then you have the collapse of the
Caliphate and then you have the
Gunpowder empires states that are
implicitly power defined by their
ability to exert power and conquer
territory rather than by something
explicitly ideological so I mentioned in
the lecture previously one problem with
this is that all the empires of that
time or gunpowder empires the spread of
military technology is terribly
important all the way from from britain
across to to japan and the different
ways in which the new the new weaponry
become engrossed into the national
culture and into the political and
economic institutions will vary a good
deal and they vary among these three
states so that what you have in the
ottoman empire really isn't quite the
same as what you have in the safavid
empire what you have in the Mughal
Empire
so I I don't really like the the phrase
gunpowder empires I don't think it gets
you very far except that it does say
implicitly that what is defining these
states is more in the
in the political military realm than in
the religious ideological realm I think
there is substance to that that would
say that the that prior to the 13th
century Islamic states or states had
primarily a Muslim citizenry had Muslim
rulers were more oriented toward issues
of ideology religious legitimacy of the
state and so forth than these later
Muslim states and that's partly because
there are changes in the in the
political thinking within Islam that I
will get to so we move along but again
gunpowder empires is not what we had in
mind early modern Muslim states was not
what we had in mind what was more
germane in the author's thinking was the
idea that you have an important
distinction that seems to arise at this
time and not earlier between land
empires and maritime empires and that
the these states represent a the
continuation of land empires into a
period which increasingly becomes
dominated by by maritime power so the
fact that this chapter includes maritime
sections in the later part of the
chapter but does not include the Muslim
states of Central Asia that were
contemporary with the Ottomans
contemporary with the Southlands and the
moguls and indeed were for all three
states very important historical and
ethnic touchstones because they were
Turkic States in Central Asia
those states in central asia did not
have any any seacoast so they are by
definition not part of a growing
maritime world last week we talked we
talked about I talked about Europe and
how we define it and so forth
next week we have a chapter called
northern Eurasia which will include
Japan China and Russia but those those
Central Asian states really we never are
going to talk about so they don't show
up in the book and so now you get into a
problem even though we were thinking in
terms of land versus Seabourn power was
there a subtext in which we were kind of
anticipating that over the course of
time the Muslims of Central Asia would
become part of Russia in other words
were we not talking about Leos Beck's or
the Crimean Tatars because we had
already kind of fallen into a 19th
century model in which Russia is already
sort of granted a hold over much much
more extensive parts of Central Asia
than they held for example in 1500 in
1500 not only was Russia not a Central
Asian power but it was very very
strongly under the influence if not the
domination of the Muslim states of
Central Asia that had initially been set
up in the course of it in the aftermath
of the Mongol conquest of the 13th
century
so you know for an American point of
view of course during the Cold War the
idea that you have a Soviet empire and
then you have things on the fringe of
the Soviet empire that becomes a
standard theme but my concern is whether
we're reading back that sort of later
thing into this earlier time there is a
you know there there are people who come
up with grand theories of how the world
works or how the world has worked and
these grand theories are pretty much
always wrong I've come up with a number
of them myself but being wrong doesn't
mean that something is not useful indeed
sometimes some of the most important
questions that have been studied by
historians have come into examination
because of some wrong idea that
historian has put forward in a
particularly forceful fashion so one of
the ideas that you have that is in
question somewhat in this chapter is the
heartland theory
there was an English geographer named
Halford mackinder who came up with the
heartland theory he was a pioneer in the
study of geography in Britain he was the
first person to teach geography at
Oxford in the before World War one he
became a professor of geography and was
one of the founding figures of the
London School of Economics and his work
was was very influential he died in 1947
so his work primarily deals with the pre
World War 2 era
he argued that there is the the great
world island which today we would call
Africa the African Eurasian landmass but
he was focusing primarily on Eurasia and
then you have an inner series of islands
around it which would include say
England and Japan then you have an outer
series of islands that would include
North and South America and Australia
but essentially the world focuses on on
something in the center and he calls
that the heartland in 1919 he wrote an
essay on this this was after in the
aftermath of World War one in which he
said whoever whoever controls the
Eastern Europe controls the heartland
whoever controls the heartland controls
the world island whoever controls the
world island controls the world and this
thinking that identified a certain
central part
of Eurasia as the heartland it was not a
great idea let me make it clear I think
he was wrong but it was a very
influential idea at the time
on the one hand German theorists in the
Nazi era took it up and said this shows
that we must conquer and assimilate
Eastern Europe to to the the Nazi Reich
Western Europe should be conquered but
Eastern Europe and particularly going
into Ukraine and Caspian Sea area with
it's about time great oil resources that
became a an important aspect of what was
called the drive to the east the Braun
nach osten from a British point of view
McKenna argued that Britain is living in
a fool's paradise if they think that
they can remain powerful simply by
controlling the seas and that
controlling the seas will not in the
long run succeed because what you need
to do is to control the heartland now
for him the heartland is Central Asia
basically what is now what became the
southern parts of Russia than the
southern parts of the Soviet Union
including Iran and Afghanistan and his
argument was that this area included
very high proportion of the world's
significant resources that it was you
could have land contact with every place
so you don't have to go around
everything and that it had great
potential if it could ever be controlled
by by people who had
the bigger and the resources to to make
it work so this was something that was
very appealing to Soviet thinkers
because they they had the heartland the
question was what to what to do with it
there are people now who look at the
difficulty of carrying out a war in
Afghanistan or the near impossibility of
carrying out a war in Iran who say well
you know if we only had bases in lose
Becca stone and Tajikistan and
Kazakhstan and so forth we could do
something so the question of who
controls a Heartland now is still there
you also have increasingly it's
increasingly evident that the resources
of Central Asia whether in terms of oil
and gas from the Caspian Sea area or in
terms of minerals from the mountains of
Central Asia that this is economically
not only a crucial sure area but one
that is sort of up for grabs because
it's under a bunch of very weak states
and no power dominates whereas Weekender
said it's very important for it for the
powers whatever the powers may be to see
this as a place to dominate
I think implicit in this was the idea
that this is where the Mongols had had
their empire and that the Mongols had
demonstrated as no one else ever had the
idea if in earth together have enormous
control in the world
the Mongols did not survive as a
coherent state very much past 1,300
but they produced a number of states
that were influenced by the Mongols and
to some degree descended from the
Mongols so that the Ottoman Empire was
came into being during the period of the
of the late Mongols and in some degree
saw a kind of legitimacy in that Mongol
that Mongol century of rule from 1200 to
1300 the Ottoman ruling family had a
fixed understanding that if the family
ever died out that the power in the
Ottoman state would be taken over by the
rulers of the Crimea or what what they
call the the CREM Tatars who were a
Turkish or a Turkic speaking population
in what is now southern Ukraine ruled by
a family the gear I family who were
different and subjected the assassins
had risen in Iran in the apple of the
mongol period there were there was a
mongol population that ended up in the
heart of afghanistan and in particular
the Moghul Empire in India is
established by people who claim descent
from the rulers in Central Asia so
the Mongols create an empire they
collapse and then you have other states
appearing on the periphery of that
Empire leaving the question of the
center of the Empire somewhat somewhat
unresolved well I don't think that
McAndrews notion of a heartland who
works politics and the way in which he
thought of it but in some ways it's a
very helpful reminder that land
connections are not necessarily inferior
to see boring connections in other words
you can always get to in pre-modern
period get from China to let us say
Paris faster by walking than by getting
on a boat in the Yellow River and going
out into the you know the Sea of Japan
and down to the South China Sea and then
into the Indian Ocean and then across
the Indian Ocean and around Africa and
up the Atlantic coast and finally you
get up to Spain and Western Europe and
then you can you know you can get on a
pony and go to Paris but these interior
lines of connection are intrinsically
more more efficient than the peripheral
lines of connection so one of the
questions that arises here is when we
talk about these empires and
particularly in the latter part of the
chapter the the maritime aspects of the
Islamic world at that time and the
extension of European powers into the
Indian Ocean into areas like Indonesia
is this what do we read into this is
this a matter that that the Europeans
really did find a better way to to
organize political and military and
ultimately economic power or do we focus
on this maritime side for other reasons
the argument for there being other
reasons is partly a historiographical
one that is to say we have sources the
Dutch East India Company which becomes
function after 1600 and a bit later the
British East India Company produced huge
archives they did a lot of business to
be sure but they did not monopolize the
business in these in these seas there
are also a huge archives in Portugal
from the earlier stage of Portuguese
influence in the Indian Ocean and
Southeast Asia are going back to Vasco
da Gama's first sailing around Africa in
the 15th century so so we have a lot of
sources and these sources are still I
know means thoroughly explored there
just aren't that many people who can
read 16th century Dutch handwriting
there are so far as I can tell precisely
to who work on this area of scholars at
least in the United States
and they're able to come out with book
after book after book of completely no
material simply by reading through the
archives of the Dutch East India Company
for the for the heartland
first of all Russian is a common
language for scholars in Europe in the
United States and this is partly a
product of of course Bolshevik
Revolution in the Cold War so that
Russian sources become less easily
explored than then sources in Western
European languages also during the
Soviet period you have very strong
ideological slant imposed on Russian
sources by communist dog-bone and yet
it's it's fairly recently become clear
that once you get past that those people
who can work with Russian sources and
who are able to sort of see through the
the ideological distortions that
affected stuff written after the
Bolshevik Revolution that there's
material dealing with Central Asia that
probably will one day will be worked
into a much more that's more a much more
effective history and people like the
u.s. Beck's will no law in the crib
Tatars will no longer be sort of
excluded from the story this has been a
very ideological issue for example we
had for many years here at Columbia a
professor who was probably the best
informed scholar in the country dealing
with
with materials written in was back which
is a Turkic language written in Cyrillic
script and through his efforts the
Columbia library has perhaps the best
collection in the country of books and
magazines newspapers published during
the Soviet period in Central Asia in
local languages but this gentleman was
also a very ardent cold warrior and did
not think that people should read
anything in Russian dealing with these
areas because anything in Russian would
be distorted by Soviet baloney and so
you had a division between right here in
this neighborhood you'd have one superb
scholar who could tell you everything in
the Uzbek sources and another one I
think it was at CCNY I'm not sure who
had read all the Russian sources but
couldn't read those back and so we never
brought it together and since the fall
of the Soviet Union the reluctance to
recognize Central Asia as a as an area
in the in the context of area studies
which had gone into sort of Eclipse
after the fall by the time of the fall
of Soviet Union has still left this area
very very poorly understood so we have a
problem of having a reservoir of
historical studies for the Central Asian
side of things comparable to what we
have for the maritime side and this
leaves us with with difficulty and sort
of correcting for the errors or the
biases that might have come into our
view of things in the very broad sense
my personal interest in this
you didn't ask but I'll tell you anyway
is embodied in an essay I finished
writing last night for a conference this
weekend called welcome to the camel zone
I raised the question of why do we refer
to two parts of the world as zones and
whether doing so is by assigning one
word to a particular geographical area
it's always going to be loaded one way
or another
and so I said for example we refer to to
Europe as being in the temperate zone
and temperate is such a nice even
sensible word as opposed to let's say
Central Africa be in the torrid zone in
the tropical zone and there you get a
very different meaning for words like
that you take the torrid zone and with
its pejorative connotations you take it
down to the American Southwest and you
call the Sun Belt and suddenly instead
of thinking of you know endless
perspiration and dying of thirst you
think of playing golf and Phoenix and
and the term just sort of gets turned
around
you could call Europe instead of calling
up the forest zone you could call the
temperate zone you could call the forest
zone because Europe a Western Europe
like Manchuria and Japan they're
parallel in the Far East we're heavily
forested areas we don't call them the
forest zone
partly because particularly in this time
period all the forests were cut down and
you know used for you know charcoal or
coke or things like that
so but forest zone would be a reasonable
term to use and of course if you read
Grimm's fairy tales you know all about
the European forests and what happens to
little boys and girls who wander off
into the forest and are never seen again
but you could also call it the mud zone
if you're dealing with the history of
transportation the great abiding
characteristic of Europe of Western
Europe was that you couldn't that the
roads were almost always impassable they
were you know we have many many many
accounts of how terrible the
transportation is and I've talked about
that in this class before so when I use
the word camel zone as a synonym for for
what I call the free energy zone that
this is the area from northwest China
across to the Atlantic Ocean and down to
the borders of sub-saharan Africa this
is the area where the most important
source of energy in the pre-modern
period was essentially free because it
was animal energy using animals that
were raised by pastoral nomads pastoral
nomads over here I'm going back to
something I talked about last week
pastoral nomads regard their livestock
as wealth a cow or horse is you know is
like a you know a deutsche mark or a you
know a Krugerrand or something it's
simply as well so you don't have
material goods of an inanimate sort you
don't acquire coins you don't acquire a
lot of jewelry you don't acquire real
estate you don't acquire many things
because as a pastoral nomads you are on
the move and you can't carry everything
around with you the question of how much
you can acquire is is relative to how
much you're willing to slap from one
pasture to another so your wealth is not
in in inanimate goods you know jewels
and coins your wealth is inanimate goods
that can walk from place to place with
you and you don't have to carry them so
result is that the livestock that they
raise in the camels own is not is not
proportional to the market for the
livestock in other words this difference
nice talking about in the Western
Hemisphere where you develop ranching
cultures where it is the the animals
that you sell or the animal parts that
you sell that determine your wealth
simply having animals on your on your
land is not in and of itself a clear
marker wealth so you don't have a you
don't have herds that rise or fall
because the market for wool or for meat
or for any other product of the herds
rises and falls because the value is is
relative to your own
cultural assignment of value to the
living animal as opposed to to simply
the products of the animal or the parts
of the animal so result is that people
who live in this zone or on the borders
of this zone come to use a tremendous
amount of animal energy to carry goods
or to haul goods or to operate
irrigation devices or to operate
industrial devices such as machines to
crush sugar cane or machines to press
linseed and get linseed oil or something
like that they use the animals and the
animals are very very close to being
free in terms of cost but what I mean by
that is that you you do have to buy the
animal but once you buy it you don't
have to feed it
it seems odd but the animal is bred on
land that cannot be used for agriculture
desert or semi desert or long grass
steppe lands in Central Asia it grows to
maturity with no dollar cost as we would
phrase it so the animal is it's a source
of wealth for the for the pastoralist
who owns the animal but it's not a it
hasn't cost anything in in financial
terms to to raise the animal so now you
take the animal you go to a market you
buy the animal the animal can now live
on on desert grazing because in most
parts of the camel zone you are very
limited in your agricultural land but
you have a lot of waste land and you can
put animals out to graze there was a
study done by a University of
Pennsylvania economist and several
colleagues in Pakistan in 1985 that
asked the question of why do you have
camel carts in use in Karachi and other
big cities in Pakistan and they did an
economic study of it and concluded the
reason is that a camel cart can compete
economically with a suzuki mini truck or
with a gasoline-powered irrigation
device or sugar cane device oppressing
device something like that because it is
so cheap and the budget was actually
published as part of this article the
costs to the person who rents out the
camel and it had you know
let's say two labouring days per year
cost of feed 0 100 labouring days non
laboring days a year cost of feed zero
but then you have the cost of the
harness which was I think 50 rupees
which is basically nothing then the cost
of medicines which traditionally would
have been much less than they are now
and then you had the replacement cost of
the animal when the animal gets worn out
and dies then you have to replace it so
there you have the ammeter due date the
amortization over a certain number of
years for the prospective lifetime of
the animal and you add it all up and you
look to open you could rent out the
camel for in the labor market and you
found out that that it was much more
efficient than a gasoline operated
device and therefore you continue to
have camel carts pulling loads because
it's efficient that would apply pretty
much throughout the camel zone to camels
and donkeys less so to two horses but
over many areas particularly in Central
Asia it would apply to point well does
not apply to mules at all because mules
are sterile and therefore they are of no
intrinsic value as living animals they
are only of value as as they are used so
you don't produce a mule and say hey I
have 150 mules aren't high rich yeah you
have 150 mules are going to go grow old
and die and then you won't have any
mules at all that isn't Madison wealth
it doesn't have any pay any interest so
to speak so mules you had to breed and
and sell so a mule train is always more
expensive than a camel caravan so result
is that for let us say from 300 BC or so
down to around 1700 here in this chapter
with the cost of transportation overland
in the camel zone is is the lowest in
the world it's incredibly inexpensive to
carry goods from one place to another
particularly in comparison to costs in
the mud zone in Europe we're carrying
goods from one place to another overland
is so expensive and so difficult that
you have people digging so they can
carry them by boat and then later on
building railroads so if you get over
the problem of of the the rainfall
muddying up the track so now there's a
problem it's often observed that the
maritime trade supply it's the overland
caravan trade of Eurasia in this period
and that may be true but I've never seen
it spelled out very did it really become
cheaper to have things go by boat from
India to Portugal around Africa from
India to England or - well yes then you
get the question of the other factors
involved such as safety what you have
for maritime training is the growth of
insurance and the growth of shared risk
in the form of joint stock companies and
then doubtedly those two things after
1600 you know make the cost of maritime
transport cheaper you also have the
growth of of market transparency
although that comes along rather slowly
if you go back to the pre 1500 period
traders tended to know what was the
price they could get for something in a
particular market but prices were never
posted it was not a public it was not a
transparent market
the reason traders knew what price they
could hope to get was because they had
an associate who wrote to them from that
market and told them what the price was
or they had had some recent experience
themselves or they had experience with
the seasonal character of certain
markets that if you bring goods from one
place to another at the right point in
the year they'll sell for a high price
but if you miss that window by a couple
of months
the price will collapse markets were
extremely opaque this was a situation
that gave a peculiar benefit for
advantage to merchants who were locked
into or not locked into but who
benefitted from inside information so
sometimes is referred to as the ethnic
division of trade so that Jewish
merchants would send letters to other
Jewish merchants saying you know you
know deal brother Avram if you get here
before November you'll be able to sell
your coffee beans at a good price
but that would only be for with people
within the network or you have Armenians
Armenian trade networks were became
terribly important particularly in Iran
all the way to Paris so the first coffee
houses in Paris are run by Armenians
with Iranian connections who know what
the prices are in different places you
have a Hindu trade network in this
period so that Hindus sell goods you
know buy goods in India sell them for
transport northward from the Persian
Gulf up to the Black Sea and they have
an interior communication system there
are actually places in southwestern Iran
far far far away from India where there
are certain caves and you go in and the
walls are covered with Shaivite Hindu
religious writings because they were
places of religious significance to
people in the Hindu trade network
Muslims of different sorts can have a
trading network so that as long as you
had no transparency in the markets there
was an advantage to having a ethnic
connection well that ethnic connection
becomes replaced or not replaced but
supplemented or complemented in the
European case by the company so that the
this massive quantity of Correspondence
that we have for the East India Company
or the Dutch East India Company this
mass amount of correspondence is the
equivalent of the the letters that that
a Jew in Baghdad would write to a
colleague in Bombay or to a colleague in
Livorno and in Italy talking about the
nature of things eventually once the
Europeans gain further control they they
stipulate prices and they try to force
everyone to to buy and sell at the
prices that the company has as
designated in so over the course of this
period you have a disappearance of of
this not a total disappearance but a
diminishing of this ethnic division of
Commerce and a growth of the markets
that are transparent but are also fixed
this in turn leads to to swindling you
know piracy things like that
particularly agents of the European
companies that do a little trading on
their side on the side of a higher price
all the customary deficiencies of a of a
fixed market system
so the intrinsic economy of land
transport in the camel zone is now being
challenged by changes in the maritime
commercial area the safety is actually
greater overland boats can sink if a
camel dies you take the things off and
you put it on another camel you you you
can't you can't have your entire cargo
sink in the on dry land so so there is
so there is safety so one of the
questions that arises is does the what
seems to be quite probably clear is that
long distance trade overland diminishes
relative to maritime trade in this
period
is this because of the new institutions
that the Europeans set up in the joint
stock companies and insurance and so on
or is it because they captures certain
strong points where they can control the
trade and ultimately set the prices and
then after setting the prices then they
eventually embark at the very end of the
period on to plantation economies where
they grow the goods and control the
price that way is this what happened hmm
well navigation doesn't change a whole
lot
period yep you can't you cannot shorten
by navigation the distance from China to
England if you have to go around Africa
ultimately you build the Suez Canal but
that's not until 1869 yes now that you
can have some some marginal improvements
in in navigation you can build larger
boats and so on but the basic economy of
the overland transport remains
for shorter distance transport not going
from China across the old Silk Road to
to Europe but within a state within the
Ottoman Empire or within the Safavid
state in Iran or within mogul India the
economy of of Overland Commerce remains
remain strong that is say we have lots
of commerce that goes up from the
Persian Gulf to the Black Sea overland
through Iran that does not go around
Africa because it's just a lot shorter
and a lot cheaper the states that are
involved the Ottoman state and the
Safavid state in the mogul state have
comparatively Valletta let's say not
minimal interests in what's happening in
the maritime realm but rather changing
interests the Mughal Empire rules most
of India and has no Navy they are
interested in trade but they're
perfectly happy to see the English or
the Dutch or anyone else the Portuguese
do the transporting saying we we produce
products we sell these products to
foreign merchants the merchants take
them away and sell them somewhere else
and that's fine with us they don't feel
they have to have a Navy to protect
their themselves from these people
the same thing with Iran Iran has
essentially no Navy except for some very
brief moments at one point when Iran
wishes to expand its Imperial reach to
go to Bahrain for to Italy on the other
side of the Persian Gulf they're
perfectly happy to
to ask the Dutch of the British to carry
them across and their boats because they
don't have their own shipping there you
know as with the Indians as with the
Muslims in India none of the moguls
there they seem to see the world in
terms of the interior lines of
communication and to under under
appreciate the changes that are taking
place in the maritime realm for the
Ottoman Empire this was for a long time
considered to be the same case as well
but just recently there is a some new
work by up a scholar at the University
of Minnesota named Giancarlo complain
that that focuses upon efforts of the
Ottomans seem to have made to extend
Ottoman power into the Indian Ocean and
through the Red Sea he has found a
surprising amount of information to show
that the Ottomans found through say the
1560s or so really did try to to be as
adventurous in the Indian Ocean as the
Europeans were being at the same time in
the Indian Ocean and the Atlantic in
other words that lead the era of
discovery was not exclusively a European
era but it was an era that the Ottomans
shared him and then you get that comes
to an end by the by the late 1500s in
the same way that a parallel effort in
China to explore
you know new areas by sea comes to an
end interestingly when the ottoman
effort to extend power into the Indian
Ocean comes to an end you have a new
plan which they have which never comes
to fruition which is to build a canal
that would connect that would go through
what is now southern Russia and it would
connect the Don River which flows into
the Black Sea the Volga River which
flows into the Caspian Sea and the
project for a Volga dong canal would
have made it possible for someone to to
go from the Mediterranean all the way to
the northern coast of Iran on the
Caspian Sea and it would have been
possible to have a maritime route by
using canals that would have been
immeasurably shorter than the routes
that the Dutch and the Portuguese and
the English were using that had to go
around Africa in Soviet times this canal
was eventually built but it was not
completed during the Ottoman period but
it it reflected
Casali argues I think it's fairly fairly
clear that this sound that it it showed
a some consideration of the relative
advantages of handling your commerce in
one fashion or handling yourself to
another having another fashion so that
the Ottomans were trying to achieve a
maritime route to Eastern products
namely those from Iran particularly silk
that would be entirely through Muslim
territories until they got to the
Mediterranean as opposed to having them
trade out of the Persian Gulf and travel
around Africa so it's not completely a
negative story with respect to
to a maritime enterprise but it is one
of the one of the general lessons that
we tend to teach dealing with chess
which is that these early modern Muslim
land empires showed a kind of a
surprisingly surprising lack of
awareness of what was happening in the
in the maritime world where the
Europeans were gaining more and more
more and more strength and more and more
confidence and the question is whether
this was a lack of awareness that was
was because they just weren't very on
the ball or whether they saw things with
having other alternatives having to do
with a continuation or extension of of
Overland trade options that were
intrinsically cheaper than the maritime
ones
this has gotten involved in a debate
which is a very not a wonderfully
productive debate but a very active
debate in the field of Middle Eastern
history which is debate over did you
have a decline of the Muslim world most
people I'm sure you teach about the
Middle East as their specialty will
bristle at the word decline because if
these are two syllables that are just
horrible syllables because they seem to
have a an implication that Islamic
society was inferior to Christian
society the seal of decline
has drawn out highly ideological
scholarship on both sides
some people arguing that it's very clear
and that the Europeans were just a hell
of lot smarter and more inventive and
aggressive and better than the Muslims
and the Muslims preferred to sit around
in their harem and you know smoke water
pipes and dream of glory days that were
long past this is the version of the
decline theory that Edward Sayid was
particularly exercised by saying that
this is decline as a substitute for
racist disparagement of non-western
peoples there are other people who say
well decline needs to be treated in a
nuanced fashion that on the one hand did
the ottoman and Safa de mogul empires
experience decline recently I heard
Giancarlo Kasauli say you know all those
empires disappeared so I guess they
declined unless you can just you know go
directly to fall without passing through
a decline on the way so so you can't you
can't
utterly eliminate the notion of decline
and other scholars have point out that
that the Arab world in its literature
has talked about decline for a long time
so that the word for decline in hip-hop
shows up
so that I'll say well you know Arabic
poetry really declined after let us say
well and we haven't had any poet since
then of the caliber of the earlier poets
except some individuals now in the 20th
century although very often when they
talk about the climb they also will
explain why say well the reason we had
decline was that we came under the
control of the Turks and and therefore
we were laboring under imperialist
domination the rulers were Turkish they
didn't understand the Arabic very well
you know poetry comes when you have
patrons who are great masters of the
language and appreciate the high quality
poetry and you just didn't didn't have
it and therefore you had decline
nowadays particularly with the warming
of relations between the current
Republic of Turkey world I think we'll
hear less and less about how terrible
the Turks were and how oppressive they
were because this like arguments dealing
with the Muslim is strongly inflected by
by ideology
so you have 303 States an ottoman state
which is by population majority
non-muslim and a mobile state which is
by population majority non-muslim and
the single or more Christians in the
Ottoman Empire the Hindus and the
Safavid state that is high percent
Muslim great homogeneity there and great
heterogeneity and the other two the
Ottomans and the moguls are both
Suneetha thus after birds are Shiites so
you have a pronounced difference between
between these and in religious terms you
have a basically homogeneous Shiite
state versus you know great
heterogeneity in the surrounding Muslim
states the bordering Muslim states if
you were to go into Central Asia and
include the khanates of the Crimea and
and the O's backs north of Iran again
you would have Sunni states although
more homogeneous Lee Muslim than either
the Ottomans for the Hindus
all three of these states were glorious
if you can if you could have gone to
Istanbul in 1530 or to Isfahan in you
know 1600 or 1630
or to Delhi or Agra
the heyday of the Mughal Empire and you
you compared it with the best that
Europe had to offer at that time in
terms of glorious artistic urban life
you would have said these are
magnificent states we have abundant
travel accounts of Europeans who went
and they were sort of overawed by many
particularly of the capital cities so
one of the problems the decline
narrative is that the people at the time
who went there usually didn't see it
that way they saw these as wealthy
thriving empires that that Europeans
might in one way another emulate except
for the fact that they did not believe
in the Christian faith so this is as
part of the problem that the decline
narrative looks at thriving successful
wealthy capital cities and says but they
are they're edging into decline
and then trying to define exactly what
it is that is causing fat I know many
Americans feel that way now about the
United States and say you know this is
really a great country a great society
we're seeing some of us are really
really wealthy but aren't we kind of
edging into decline and isn't there
something about say the projection of
our debt over the next thirty years or
the the rise of China or the impending
change and the climb or disappearance of
affordable gasoline or something aren't
there things there that are pushing us
into a an incipient an incipient decline
well you know if this depends on your
your your party affiliation and your
your taste for gloom whether you fall
into this kind of this way of thinking
but but the the comparison here is that
when we look at this period from 1500 to
1750 and look at these three these three
states how much of the historical
construction that we put on this history
is the result of hindsight now are we
grouping them and defining their several
crises that they've had because we know
that that they are going to come to an
end and this is the exclusion of the
centrum part of the camel zone because
we know that it's all going to end up
under the control of the Russians and
end up in sort of a post-soviet state of
chaos and disorder do we need to to to
remind ourselves that historical
objectivity should include some sort of
guarding against an over an over reading
of the hindsight that we have because we
know what's going to to come later in
some ways it's it's easier to write
about the Roman Empire where everybody
knows that then it is going to fall and
you can appreciate it at its heyday than
it is to to write about these states
where you know there appears to be so
much ideological baggage accompanied
with the question of whether they are at
the pinnacle of something or whether
they post pinnacle moment where
their fall is not yet fully appreciated
this has been an extremely general
lecture has it's quite obvious and I
will talk on Thursday in on some issues
that are more particular within this
particularly the the nature of the
crises that appear to have occurred in
the area of taxation landholding and and
changes in the military